[Music]
well ken two years ago right now people
were locked down in their homes we had
to flatten the curve
you remember flattening the curve well i
remember hearing about it but it turns
out you and i and some brave
staff people kept coming in and putting
out live shows so i heard about it and
we heard about but the curve apparently
had to be flattened yes and then later
apparently two weeks we had to be masked
and then apparently we didn't yeah and
then apparently we all had to be
vaccinated and then apparently we didn't
and um
some people are still bathing in that
fear porn that's out there yes in the
middle of all of that there's um
a complete i mean we shut down the
american economy yes for
you know what 60 to 90 days and we're
now experiencing inflation as a result
of that
uh lack of production creating shortages
and now a an over
zealous
uh retail
thrive driving
supply being driving demand way high and
supplies still out of kilter two years
later we're trying to recover from the
flattening of the curve
but one of the things i didn't know
until i picked up this from nbc news
this week
they're calling the ppp plan the biggest
fraud
in a generation the looting of the covid
relief plan yeah remember ppp oh yeah
where businesses were not going to you
know the economy was going to collapse
if the government didn't step in right
just like we were going to die
we were all going to die if we didn't
flatten the curve right the economy was
going to collapse and everybody was
scared and everybody's running around
screaming and screeching at the top of
their lungs and so the government lines
up
this
blows
my mind um
90
i'm sorry
let's just say okay they bought
lamborghinis they brought ferraris and
bentley's here's the article and teslas
of course lots of teslas many have
participated in what prosecutors are
calling the largest fraud in u.s history
the theft of hundreds
of billions
of dollars in tax care payer money
intended to help those harmed
by the covenant 19 pandemic
instead uh these
frosters came in and couldn't resist
purchasing luxury automobiles mansions
private jet flights and swanky vacations
they came into the riches by
participating in what experts say is the
theft
of as much as 80 billion dollars
80 billion dollars oh yeah of the ppp
was fraudulent use and theft of the 800
billion that was handed out in the
coveted relief plan known as the
paycheck protection program or ppp
that's on top of the 90 billion to 400
billion believed to have been stolen
from the other 900 billion under the
coveted unemployment relief program
right so we've got 800 billion and 900
billion we dumped into saving the world
well we have a theme dave so what
happens is when government says they're
going to come in to save the day
government doesn't operate efficiently
or effectively and what we had was a
small business administration on the
first half of this the ppp saying hey
write us a letter this is a this is
about as fundamental as it was and tell
us why you need it so what do these
people do these scumbags they go let's
take advantage of the us government
because they're a bunch of morons and
we're going to get money and they got it
well the government just said here's a
check here's a check here's a check
here's a check because they wanted to
save the day exactly well and the trump
administration truly believed and they
were screwed in the head
that
they had to get this money plugged into
the economy fast to offset
the the drop
to offset the quarantine right
and when you go
at that rate of speed you don't have any
way to verify
and put in place that's correct and you
drop trillions
and trillions of dollars out there and
now we're finding out that well over 10
percent of it unbelievable
north of 500 billion dollars now
went to people
who did not have an unemployment problem
and did not even qualify for ppp because
all they did was say
sign this document and check here that
you really
are due this money right they didn't
even look no yeah i have 46 employees
i happen to work out in my basement have
no employees but i have 46 employees and
here's the name of my company people
were going to state records and pulling
company names off of state records and
filing under that with false addresses
basically creating a form of identity
theft and getting checks for hundreds of
thousands of dollars sent to them to
keep their business open and they didn't
even have a business yeah this is what
happens when leaders lead from
desperation desperation and fear it's
exactly what happens it was full
and when people are panicking they're
not leaders that's correct and i don't
care if you're a democrat you're a
republican you're a lefty you're a
massacre you're a righty you're an
anti-massacre you're a vaccer or you're
an anti-vaxxer if you're in a full-on
panic you're straight up stupid that's
right and so what was happening is the
government was trying to give the
illusion of we're in control we got you
and the fact of the matter is they
didn't and this is taxpayer dollars
let's bring this back to when you hear
numbers like that i want to make sure
you folks catch this because those
numbers are so big it kind of feels like
oh it's that's just so that's your
money that is taxpayer dollars being
fraudulently spent and all because
leaders are trying to give the illusion
that they can solve your problems by the
way they're the source of the shutdown
where the governors
and the senators
trump all of them they all signed on to
this
shutdown and it broke businesses and in
their desire to help the businesses they
broke
they end up wasting money and i got to
tell you something it ought to be a wake
up call to the american ought to stop
and go
hey yeah
this is this whole thing yeah
was off yeah
yeah and let's stop blaming some kind of
bad movie right here
but
500
billion dollars
paid out to people
that didn't even own businesses or that
weren't even unemployed
in the name of
panic
brought on by
false sets of assumptions about numbers
oh god it just is it's a
it's a case study in leadership
not leading
and in the nanny state run amok that's
true and so the people are screaming you
have to take care of us because now you
made us locked us in our house and now
you have to feed us yeah and uh man
people you people i'm telling you
if you ever allow your government to do
this to you again you're a bunch of
freaking sheep
but yeah because this the the results of
this
are going to ripple through our economy
for a decade
500
million dollars and here's the deal you
can do something about a trillion
dollars you know what you can do vote go
vote anybody that was a party to this
kind of google support oh
a governor to a senator to a president
you can vote send them home good god
this is the ramsey show